we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's a question about a trump
resignation that has been coming in
regularly let's take a listen
hey david i was just wondering if there
is any validity to the idea
of donald trump resigning mike pence
being sworn in and then
pardoning him for his crime sort of like
what happened when richard nixon left
office and gerald ford cleaned the slave
richard nixon
yeah i mean listen there's validity
there is validity to the idea it's
something that could happen
i i don't think it's very likely and i
know a lot of you are wondering about
this the idea would be
trump anticipates that he could be in
legal trouble after leaving office
um the way to preempt that would be he
resigns
and mike pence gives him a preemptive
blanket pardon the reason i think it's
unlikely
is because it's just something that's so
rare in american history that doesn't
mean it couldn't be done so if you if
you gave me
just an even odds bet and you say david
bett does trump resign and
have pence pardon him or not i bet that
it doesn't happen
if you tell me to put sort of a number
on it my thought is that there's like an
eight to ten percent chance that
something like that happens now
many things happen in the world that
have an eight or ten percent chance
so these could certainly be famous last
words but i don't think that it is a
likely
thing to happen um it uh listen the next
ten weeks could be crazy so really
anything could happen but i
if you if you put me if you hold a gun
to my head and say david bett
does this happen or not i bet that it
doesn't happen
we will have a fantastic bonus show
today it turns out
that chad wolfe actually did not have
the authority to restrict
the daca program which has been the
subject of much controversy during the
trump
presidency a federal judge has ruled in
that way
we are also going to talk about deutsche
bank suggesting a 5
privilege tax on people choosing to work
from home
i'm against that and i will tell you why
on the bonus show
and we will also talk about how there
are many obama
former obama staffers who are suggesting
to joe biden
he needs to go wild with executive
orders
to undo the damage done by donald trump
and of course you know
that the moment joe biden tries to do
that the same trumpists who
loved trump's orders executive orders
will say oh that's
that's authoritarian using executive
orders is authoritarian we're going to
talk about that
and much more on today's bonus show get
instant access by becoming a member
at joinpakman.com